I'm just going to interrupt you because
we understand that the plane we now see
on our screen is the plane uh that we
have been waiting for uh due to land at
224 and here it is arriving at Stansted
Airport bringing back those 40 British
Nationals that have been evacuated from
Sudan uh formal flights uh scheduled uh
Britain in total bringing 301 people out
so far thousands in Sudan but these are
the first 40 British Nationals to touch
down on UK soil
well actually there you have it a safe
landing there for that smart Wings
playing carrying those British Nationals
and presumably other passengers as well
but we were talking about what happens
next for those people and also the fact
that this is just one of the first
planes
um that the UK government has organized
to bring Nationals back to the UK
it is we understand there are going to
be more flights that will be landing
over the next um few hours at least two
Landing very late this evening again
coming into downstairs airport as for
where they go now well first of all
these people will be extremely extremely
exhausted and they will have been
waiting to get on a flight like this
back home for days ever since they
learned that British diplomats had been
brought here on Sunday